hello everyone I'm Esther and I'm a post
at the University of Washington today I
want to tell you about a joint work
between me Steve WF gang and Christian
in which we investigate how we can
extend the flight envelope of commercial
aircraft in the highspeed regime and the
main idea is that we mitigate a safety
critical aerodynamic phenomenon called
transonic Airi Buffet which as you can
see in this animation here here
describes self- sustained shock wave
oscillations that occur on the aircraft
wing and that endanger a flight safety
and based on experimental wind tunnel
tests we were able to demonstrate that
post trailing edges are actually able to
mitigate transonic air for Buffet so
with a quite uh simple modification of
the Wings trailing Edge we might be able
to fly at higher aircraft speeds without
compromising our safety and in today's
talk I will give you a highlevel
overview of our work involving the
experimental setup the main findings and
also a physical explanation about the
underlying mechanism by which post
triling edges are able to influence the
shock wve
motion so if you're interested in any
further details uh you're very welcome
to check out our archive paper by using
the QR code in the upper right corner
okay as I mentioned um earlier this is
Joint work involving the University of
Washington and The Institute of
aerodynamics of rwth Aran in
Germany now let's start with a big
picture when we are designing an
aircraft at some point we determine the
flight envelope which defines
operational limits to ensure safe
aircraft
operations and in a simplified manner
the flight envelope diagram can look
like this sketch here and you can see
that it defines limits with respect to
the aircraft speed so the velocity and
the load factor which is the ratio of
lift to weight now we all want to arrive
at our desired destination as fast as
possible so it would be great if we
could extend the flight envelope to
higher aircraft speeds but unfortunately
a safety critical aerodynamic phenomenon
usually arises at these high velocities
which is called transonic air for buffet
and to understand what's happening let
us zoom in onto a cross-section of the
aircraft Wing so here you can see a
sketch of the air foil and although the
aircraft is operated at subsonic speeds
the flow acceleration along the leading
part usually creates a supersonic region
with a MTH number greater than one and
this is why we uh usually refer to these
flow conditions as trans and Sonic
because they are in the transitional
regime between sub and
supersonic now as you can see here the
supersonic region is abruptly terminated
by a shock wave and the flow Downstream
of the shock wave is subsonic again and
the shock wave is actually a very
interesting flow phenomenon because the
flow conditions basically change
discontinuously across the shock wave so
for example we have a discontinuous
density jump within our flow field
and now it is getting dangerous when the
shock wave starts to oscillate along the
airfall as you can see in this animation
here so this is actually the result of a
numerical simulation that a colleague of
mine at rwth conducted and he was kind
enough to let me use it here so these
shock wave oscillations that you see
here are what we call transonic air for
buff it and why is it harmful well it
can impose unsteady aerodynam damic
loads acting on the wing structure and
these loads can result in structural
failure and we don't want to sit in an
aircraft that is actually
experiencing this kind of structural
failure so at all times we want to avoid
transonic air for buff it and this is
why the respective flow conditions are
excluded from the flight
envelope however what if we are able to
mitigate the safety critical phenomenon
then we might be able to fly to fly at
higher aircraft speeds without
compromising our safety and in our work
we were able to demonstrate based on
experimental measurements that it is
possible to mitigate transonic air for
Buffet by using porous trailing edges so
a technique that is quite simple robust
easy to
manufacture and very flexible with
respect to the design
choices so let me now show you what we
did here you can see a sketch of the
experimental setup in a top view and I'm
actually only showing you the extract of
the whole wind tunnel facility in which
the measurements actually took place so
these are the sidewalls of our wind
tunnel and this is our air fo model and
we prescribe a free steering Mark number
of 76 so that the flow conditions are
similar to what we would expect in real
flight conditions and since we have
Optical access at uh both sides of the
window tunnel we can use highspeed
cameras to um observe the flow field so
actually we are using a synchronized
setup of two different measurement
techniques so this here is our
background oriented sherance setup which
we use to visualize density gradients so
remember that I said that the shock wave
is basically a discontinous density jump
so this measurement technique precisely
tells us where the shock wave is located
in a Time resolve fashion and then
simultaneously we also conducted
particle image veloc symmetry
measurements to extract the velocity
field Downstream of the shock wave so um
more precisely we are interested in the
separated boundary layer Downstream of
the shock wave because as you will see
later on this is essential to explain
the underlying U mechanism that results
in a successful Buffet
mitigation So speaking of Let Me Now
show you the air design that we used to
mitigate transonic air
Buffet here's a photo of the airor model
again in a top view but now the flows
from top to bottom and you can see that
our model has an exchangeable trailing
Edge part um why because we want to
replace the traditional solid trailing
Edge by a purse trailing Edge and purse
trailing edges are already known to
reduce acoustic noise that is generated
at the trailing Edge so with our study
we could show that Pro trailing edges
have the second benefit of mitigating
transonic air for Buffet meaning that we
can potentially fly at higher aircraft
speeds and simultaneously reduce the
noise
emissions so for the purse trailing Edge
design we made two conscious design
choices to optimize the aerodynamic
performance as you can see um here we
incorporate an impermeable layer along
the center line of the trailing Edge to
avoid a mass Flex between the lower and
the upper part because such a mass Flex
would otherwise result um in a lift
degradation and this would reduce the
efficiency of our aircraft and then
additionally we also incorporate a
perforated surface layer on top of the
purse material um to reduce the surface
roughness which would otherwise
massively disturb the flow field
resulting in a higher drag which we
obviously would like to avoid because
this would require higher few
consumption of the
aircraft now in the experimental
measurements we actually looked at two
different pearse materials and we will
refer to the respective trailing edges
as pt1 and pt2 and uh both materials
were very successful in damping the uh
undesired shock wave oscillations
associated with transonic a for Buffet
now in the top view you can hardly see
any difference between pte 1 and pte 2
but in the side view photos and also in
the cad animations you can clearly see
that they are made up of completely
different
structures now that we know how the
experimental setup and the model looks
like let us uh take a look at some
results so at first I will show you the
dat data related to the ordinary solid
trailing Edge so that we have a
reference how the fully developed
transonic Buffet looks like which makes
it easier to assess how the pte modify
the flow field and how successful they
are in damping transonic a
buffet so here in this lower figure we
have um the shock wave position
normalized by the cord length as a
function of time and we can see that the
shock wave oscillates quite dramatically
in the C of time so actually when we
zoom in we can see kind of a periodic
motion so we applied fft the forier
transform to get the respective
frequency content and in this power
Spectrum here we see a very distinct
Peak at about 180 htz which tells us
that the shock wave moves predominantly
at about 180
Hertz so this is how fully developed
transonic Buffet looks like now we will
look at the same data but in the case
where the post trailing edges are
deployed and I'm using the same colors
as before so blue is the ordinary solid
trailing Edge and orange is related to
pt1 and yellow to pte
2 now we can see a dramatic reduction of
the Shockwave oscillation when the post
trailing edges are deployed so in fact
it becomes even more apparent when we
look at the power Spectra obtained from
applying the
fft so the frequency Peak that was
originally uh associated with transonic
Al buffet in the reference configuration
so in the blue uh plot over there is
completely eliminated when we're using
PSE trailing edges and this gives us
evidence that the energy contained in
the shock wave motion is substantially
reduced when we are using PSE trailing
edges meaning that the shock wave barely
moves anymore and this is a great result
with a potentially significant impact on
the aviation industry um because we can
mitigate transonic air for buffet with a
quite simple modification of the
trailing
Edge okay great we have shown that postt
trailing edges are able to mitigate
transonic air for bu
it but you might have seen or noticed
that the location of these po trailing
edges is much more further Downstream
compared to the shock wave itself so you
might have wondered how these devices
can actually influence the shock wave
motion so dramatically although their
spatial separation doesn't allow a
direct
interaction and there are actually
theories related to transonic alab
Buffet stating that the shock wave
oscillation is coupled with with a Time
varying um size of the boundary layer
Downstream of the shock wave so in other
words when the boundary layer
experiences a Time dependent thickening
and thinning which we also call a
boundary layer breathing this is
connected to the shock wave
oscillation and to see if such a
connection between shock wve and
separated boundary layer is able to
explain the successful Buffet mitigation
that we observe when we are using post
trailing edges We additionally
additionally conducted particle image
Velo symmetry measurements to observe uh
the boundary layer Downstream of the
shock wave so um more precisely we want
to see how the boundary layer changes
when we are using post trailing edges
and how this change behavior is linked
to the uh Shockwave uh
motion now I will explain um our theory
about the underlying physical mechanism
based on some illustrative sketches but
if you're curious to see complementary
evidence based on our measurement data
please check out the uh archive
paper now when we are deploying purse
trailing edges fluid penetrates the
purse material and so the kinetic energy
of the flow close to the wall is reduced
consequently the recirculation region
enlarges
and the boundary layer thickness
increases and we can derive that from
our velocity measurements a thicker
boundary layer has a increased
resistance with respect to incoming
disturbances and this basically provokes
two effects so first the boundary layer
breathing that I previously mentioned is
reduced and this also dams pressure
fluctuations in the trailing Edge region
with a direct impact on the shock wave
motion and then secondly the larger
recirculation region acts as a buffer at
the shock foot so instabilities
associated with the shock wave are damed
and both these effects add up to an
overall reduction of the shock wave
oscillation that we observed in our
data so basically the connection between
the shock wave itself and the separated
boundary layer Downstream of the shock
wave can explain why we are able to
mitigate transonic AA Buffet by using
post trailing edges although the spatial
distance between the trailing Edge and
the shock doesn't allow a direct
interaction okay so I hope that you
enjoyed this brief overview of our work
on mitigating transonic air for Buffet
which can
prospectively allow us to extend the
flight envelope of future
aircraft now let me Briefly summarize
we saw that a safety critical
aerodynamic phenomenon involving shock
wave oscillations on the aircraft Wings
doesn't allow us to fly at higher
aircraft speeds without endangering
flight safety and then based on
experimental measurements we were able
to demonstrate that P trailing edges are
actually able to damp these undesired
shock wave oscillations associated with
transonic a buffet and we were also able
to explain the underlying physical
mechanism by analyzing how the boundary
layer Downstream of the shock wave is
modified by the post trailing edges and
how this is linked to the shock wve
motion and here I also like to mention
that there are other studies in in the
literature showing that PO trailing
edges reduce acoustic noise at the
trailing Edge so we hope that our work
contributes to faster and safer Air
transport while simultaneous ously
reducing the aircraft noise emissions so
thank you very much for your interest in
our work and for watching and I hope to
see you again soon bye